well that would have two possible
consequences impact the impact of course
that I want primarily is the very
conventional one of the listener who
retains something that's the primary
issue that some afterimage not
necessarily in detail in some portion of
the audience and could be quite small is
prevalent that's probably when I get
evidence of that the most significant
part of what I do it doesn't matter who
that is and it it's the I think always a
mistake for us to think only in terms of
professionals in our field when we're
evaluating that much broader than that
obviously I like it when other people
who are composing are interested in what
I'm doing and I like it when I'm in a
situation where the reaction is strong
enough where it can be even contrary as
long as it's a reaction and as long as
there's something that's retained to me
the biggest issue in in music that's
being written today is is memorability
or the lack of it and it's not even that
a specific tune or rhythm or chord is
remembered but that's something unique
about the profile is retained and I
guess the bid my happiest index is way
when some group of performers decides to
perform something again then I know that
the afterimage has has held had some
tenacity
in the sense that many of us who are
more or less my age began working in in
this music at a time of rather stringent
stylistic restriction that is an
assumption almost worldwide that
significant concert music would accept
certain premises and to the extent that
our generation in various ways most of
us who've achieved some significance
needed to find cracks or evasions or
contradictions to this assumption I feel
like I was part of a significant
movement towards reopening a number of
compositional roads and the strange part
about that was to observe in the later
60s early 70s to notice the number of
strange tributaries and sort of real
guard actions that were going on among
and always at that point I would say to
the pretty uniform displeasure of our
former teachers and and to a certain
level of establishment thinking that so
many of us felt it was necessary to to
really fundamentally question on the
other hand we wind up at this point
probably many of us grateful for having
learned a discipline before having come
through at the time when certain very
demanding skills were being taught and
in that sense we are a link with a very
much older tradition in terms of the
communication of concert music
discipline
and I don't envy my own tanglewood
students now coming from a very
different world where almost anything
any note they put down is right because
having had to go through a time where
the criteria were clear I think does
train 10 in a way that can be useful so
I think what I recognize people have
asked me why there are a lot of
composers born in 1938 who have done
good music and I think the answer would
be that we all went through hell we were
in a kind of a boot camp together and in
feeling like we needed to survive that
and reorganize it we became quite strong
I think my proudest achievement is to is
to regroup and continue to explore and
continue to essentially far away even
after what is for many composers a very
dislodging experience which is to have
an opera done at tremendous expense
which most of the critics disapproved up
I think you know I think we learned they
say you learn the most from from what is
regarded as failures I think I found
that out I had to actually almost
eliminate that piece from Maya from my
thinking I had to divorce it for a
number of years and in doing so I took
other roads and I think built up some
muscle
I think if my music were to be perceived
really accurately say in 25 years it
would I hope be heard as one of the most
ambitious enterprises towards
transforming and retaining a number of
already dismissed traditions that is to
say I think my specialty is finding
value and liveliness in discarded debris
of earlier traditions and if that were
to prove if we're if it were to just
show in general that the refuse heap has
a trends amount of interesting material
in it I think that would be a valuable
contribution they say everything that
moves forward destroy something and
that's true I think the question I've
asked is does it destroy as much as we
think of it are they already are I mean
I have students in the profession with
whom I know I had significant encounters
which may be opened up usually the the
useful ones were open where it opened up
a gate to some unused part of their
arsenal and so I'm confident about that
already there's really good evidence out
there every once in a while ago to a
concert were were one of my tanglewood
class for maybe even back in nineteen
eighty four and i feel i can remember
almost the day then encounter took place
that mighta that was valuable
I'd like to actually have all of my
skills and interests viable and
functional that is to say I'm trying I'm
actually rebuilding myself as a jazz
musician now I really feel like the hot
the idea that as you go along that you
should put things away is what I'm
working against I'd like to be able to
play the instruments I've always played
I like to sometimes be able to conduct
even on short notice with considerable
communicative skill and I'd like to be
writing pieces which did things that I'm
unfamiliar with if they are young it's
that they are expected to or perhaps
driven to assimilate so many
possibilities that the excitement of
limitation or the focus of limitation is
very hard for them to find because now
of course communication is so vast that
any music in the world is available
instantly and there are so many cultures
that do interesting things there's about
900 categories of pop music that we see
her ear at the Grammys all of that is
very difficult to file down and shape
into something very perspicuous and
powerful that is not all those things
but is a selection I think that's for
I'm very grateful that I'm not starting
out now and what I try to do with the
people i work with that are starting out
is I try to impress upon them that every
talented composer will write one good
piece but writing a lot means a broad
and very substantial base which is
wyd and doesn't topple